Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du der neue Papst-Fan? Bist du ein neuer Papst-Fan? Bist du immer noch Papst-Fan? Du hast dich ja wohlwollend geäußert.
So schnell kann man das noch nicht sagen. Ich bin erst mal erfreut darüber, dass ein Papst sich Leo XIV nennt, denn das bezieht sich natürlich auf eine lange Leo-Tradition. Vor allem knüpft er ja dann wohl an, an Leo XIII. Das war der Papst.
Meinst du?
Ja, das macht man schon aus Gründen.
Leo XIV schließt an Leo XIII an, kann sein.
Ja, das möchte man. Also man möchte in einer Tradition stehen.
Ich wollte wegen den Zahlen machen, aber du hast nämlich recht. Man kann auch an andere Leones anschließen.
Man möchte an Leo XIII anschließen. Der Ende des 19. Jahrhunderts, ja, der erste Papst, der eine Sozialenzyklika rausgegeben hat. Also das, was dann später auch katholische Soziallehre genannt wurde, das ist die Reaktion der katholischen Kirche. Sicherlich auch auf den Sozialismus, auf Marx und die Folgenden. Nicht, dass ich jetzt ein riesengroßer Fan der katholischen Soziallehre bin. Ich sehe da natürlich aus marxistischer Perspektive durchaus Schwierigkeiten. Aber was natürlich wichtig ist, ist, dass das ein Papst ist, der das Soziale in den Mittelpunkt rückt, der eine hoffentlichen Kirchenpolitik auch für die Armen machen wird und der damit auch ein Stachel im Fleisch sein wird. All jener, die jetzt gerade gratulieren, wie zum Beispiel Donald Trump. Also, dass er mit Donald Trump viel gemein hat, danach sieht es jetzt gerade nicht aus und das ist ja schon mal erfreulich.
Ja, Donald Trump freut sich auf ein Treffen mit dem Papst. Ich finde, also ungehörig war er schon, sich selbst in Papstrobe zu zeigen und dann später zu erklären, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. Das hat jemand gemacht, mir hat es gefallen, wir haben es gepostet. Mehr Distanz kann man gar nicht haben. Sich auf ein Treffen mit dem Papst zu freuen, ohne dass schon eine Audienz anberaumt ist, finde ich auch ungehörig.
Und das liegt beim Papst und nicht bei Donald Trump.
Genau, also Trump denkt wahrscheinlich, der Papst kommt dann zu ihm ins Weiße Haus oder so.
Also das kann passieren.
Ich wette, er ist jung, er ist 69, er ist nur zwei Monate älter als Merz, also noch ein junger Mann. Wir wissen aber von Franziskus, er hat Argentinien nie besucht, sondern es war eine ideelle Verbindung. Er war als allererstes in Brasilien. Es würde mich nicht wundern, aber ich kann keine Prognose machen, ich will jetzt keine Feuer und Finger und so, aber wenn der neue Papst relativ früh in den ersten zwei Jahren einen Besuch in Mexiko macht, würde mich das nicht wundern. Das würde programmatisch genau passen und niemals zu Lebzeiten wieder in Amerika auftauchen. Er hat sich sowieso schon biografisch dagegen entschieden, Jahrzehnte in Peru und so weiter. Ich glaube, für Trump ist noch das eine oder andere Wunder abzuholen, denn ich dachte gestern auch zuerst, ist das das, was Trump noch gefehlt hat, ein Papst. Nur Trump imaginiert sich jetzt so eine Nähe, mit der man durchaus spielen kann von Seiten des Vatikans. Ja, ganz genau. Also in der ARD gestern oder bei Phoenix war ein junger Mann, der kommentierte, das ist auch eine Kampfansage. Dann war die Frage, gegen wen? Kampf klingt ja auch ganz schön gefährlich. Und die Antwort war gegen Trump und die Kollegen auf dieser Welt.
Kann ich mir gut vorstellen, wir werden sehen. Er ist jedenfalls jemand, der Franziskus nahe stand. Das ist ja auch bei seinem ersten Auftritt klar geworden. Er hat mehrfach betont, wie wichtig die Friedensbotschaft, die christliche ist und dass er dazu aufruft. Jetzt ist er noch nicht so konkret geworden. Das ist auch unüblich oder wäre unüblich, wenn er das geworden wäre. Insofern können wir da sehr gespannt sein. Ich glaube auch, dass für ihn das nicht gerade besonders relevant ist, darüber nachzudenken, wann er in Washington auftaucht. Das ist auch einfach provinziell gedacht dann von den Amerikanern, wie die Deutschen auch immer provinziell über ihren deutschen Papst nachdenken. Es ist die Weltkirche. Da spielen am Ende die US-Amerikanischen Katholiken nicht die Hauptrolle.
Spielt ja nicht mal in Amerika.
Eben.
Als Christen. So, nun war das am 8. Mai, dass der Papst auf den Balkon tritt und erstmal einen Friedensgruß herausschickt. Ist ja auch für Italien und selbst, wenn es nicht in Italien wäre, ist es für die Welt ein wichtiges Datum, der Ende zweiter Weltkrieg und so. Und ich möchte zwei Clips spielen. Denn zurück ins Provinzielle, wir haben eine AfD, die uns bedroht, bei der Auskennner wie Justus Bender sagen, für die Gerichte soll es jetzt eigentlich unerheblich sein, wie groß oder klein die Partei ist. Also das sind einfach Sachfragen zu entscheiden, dadurch, dass eine Bundesbehörde, die dafür zuständig ist, auch ein bisschen institutionalisierte, wehrhafte Demokratie zu sein. Zu sagen, wenn die das Urteil sprechen, gilt das schon mal. Jetzt haben sie einen kleinen Rückzieher gemacht, also das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, und hat gesagt, wir setzen das aus. Was aber nur bedeutet, wir warten die gerichtliche Klärung an, ab. Nancy Faeser hat also in ihrem letzten Move gesagt, das soll jetzt mal aus der Politik raus in der Justiz entschieden werden, wie man damit umgeht. Wir alle hören ja schon von Höcke, dass man ihn jetzt als wie auch immer bezeichnen darf, weil Gerichte das bestätigt haben. Also warten wir diese gerichtliche Bestätigung ab, und ich finde diesen Move zu sagen, wir legen jetzt 1100 Seiten vor, das meiste davon wird schon öffentlich sein, also wenig Überraschungsmaterial, so und es ist einfach wahrscheinlich chronologisch oder mit einem ordentlichen Sachregister oder wie auch immer. Aber während dieses Gerichtsverfahrens wird ja wahrscheinlich dann auch dieser Text der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung gestellt, über den muss ja dann gesprochen werden. Und das jetzt überhaupt das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz sagte, die sind gesichert rechtsextrem, ist ja so ein kleiner Punkt, hinter den man nicht zurück kann. Also man kann jetzt nicht einfach Opa Enno oder so weiter durchlabern lassen, wenn eigentlich das im Raume steht. Sondern es gibt diesen ganz kurzen Moment, in den auch ein AfD-Wähler sich noch mal kurz mit sich und vielleicht auch mit anderen damit ins Benehmen setzen muss, dass man hier eine gesichert rechtsextreme Partei unterstützt und wählt.
Glaubst du, dass das in irgendeiner Weise für AfD-Wähler von Relevanz sein kann? Denn dieses Siegel gesichert rechtsextrem hat man sich ja auch denken können, denn ohne einen Bundesverfassungsschutz hätte man das auch machen können. Und jetzt hat man das und die Argumentation der AfD-Wähler könnte sein, ja, da sieht man es wieder, diese Kartellparteien haben das jetzt schön anberaumt, dass ja auch noch die AfD verboten werden soll. Also bin ich in einer wunderbaren Widerstandsposition.
Also ich finde, die Frage ist jetzt die allerwichtigste, ob das jemanden kümmert. Denn es gibt jetzt sozusagen zwei alternative Wege. Das eine ist, da sieht man es wieder, wir als die aufstrebende Parallelgesellschaft, sozusagen auf der Siegerstraße, man sieht ja auch, die Zustimmung wächst und so weiter. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch warten, bis es passiert. Und dann ist das Deutschland aber wieder normal. Oder aber es bringt einen in eine Rechtfertigungspflicht, dass man eben nicht einfach weiter abwarten kann, sondern vielleicht auch noch mal einen kleinen Gedanken drauf verschwenden muss, was hier im eigenen Lager, auf dem man sich auf der Siegerstraße fühlt, passiert.
Es ist ja auch für, sagen wir, Linksliberale bis Linke nicht so leicht gerade. Also dass die AfD verboten gehört, könnte man ja auch begründen, ohne dass man jetzt mit dem Verfassungsschutz kommt. Jetzt gibt es aber einen ganz positiven Bezug auf den Verfassungsschutz, von dem die Linken, also die radikaleren Linken immer sagen, der muss sowieso abgeschafft werden. Und auch liberalere Positionen, wie jetzt eine von von Ronnen Steinko oder so, ist ja keine, die sagt, ja gut, dass wir diesen Verfassungsschutz haben, dem haben wir ja schon immer geglaubt, den brauchen wir unbedingt. Sondern da gibt es ja eine Kritik am Verfassungsschutz und zugleich aber jetzt ein positiver Bezug die ganze Zeit auf den Verfassungsschutzbericht.
Ja, genau. Also der Verfassungsschutz hat ja eine Wesenswandelung durchgemacht, nachdem zum Beispiel die Linken in Thüringen gesagt haben, okay, der NSU wurde bei uns gegründet und wir wissen nicht genau, wie viel der Verfassungsschutz damit drin hängt. Also nehmen wir den, ich weiß gar nicht aus welcher jüdisch-politischen Organisation, den Chef und machen ihn zum Verfassungsschutzpräsidenten so. Und mit Halderwang als Nachfolger von Maaßen, was ja auch ein Kulturwandel, der sozusagen sich niedergeschlagen hat. Also das kriegt man schon noch erklärt so. Aber das ist eben der Punkt, man muss sich halt damit befassen. Also man muss es schon erklären. Man kann jetzt nicht einfach so weiterhin mitlaufen, indem man sagt, oh mein Leben ist so anstrengend, ich mache mir Sorgen um, wer über meinen Gartenzaun springt. Ich will jetzt mal AfD, aber eigentlich habe ich damit nichts zu tun. Also dieses total passive, ausgeschaltet sein. Ich finde das gut, wenn jemand eine energischen Rede vorträgt und sei es nur in einem 30 Sekunden YouTube-Clip, ansonsten habe ich damit nichts zu tun. Ich befasse mich mit nichts.
Aber wie ist es von einer linken Position? Weil es ist ja jetzt keineswegs so, dass der Verfassungsschutz, auch wenn es da einige Personalentscheidungen gegeben hat, eine linke Kampfgruppe ist. Noch immer gibt es ja einen Verfassungsschutzbericht, in dem beispielsweise irgendwelche linken Publikationen, Podcasts und so weiter als extremistisch aufgeführt werden, bei dem man so denkt, naja gut, die fragen sich, ob der Kapitalismus ideal sein kann und beantworten diese Frage mit Nein. Ist das gleiche Extremismus? Ist überhaupt, wenn man in diesen Extremismus-Kategorien denkt. Also ich glaube, dass das schon jetzt eine gewisse Schwierigkeit darstellt und vielleicht benötigt man sie gar nicht. Also das ist vielleicht eher ein Bericht, den man in Anschlag bringen kann gegen ein eher konservatives Wälder-Spektrum. Aber das ist vielleicht gar nicht, worauf man sich so sehr positiv beziehen braucht.
Ich will mal eine Metagegenfrage formulieren. Man muss sich ein ganz klein wenig mit irgendwas beschäftigen in diesem politischen Felder, um überhaupt zu so einer Frage zu kommen. Ein Wesenswandel im Verfassungsschutz. Oder was sagt mir der Verfassungsschutz, wenn er irgendwas mitteilt? Folge ich dem jetzt oder nicht? Das heißt ja, da gibt es schon eine Grundlage, auf der man nach Antworten sucht. Es ist nicht einfach nur ein gefühliges Mitlaufen, sondern so ein bisschen... Und jetzt ist meine Frage, inwieweit kann man uns vom, ich sag mal, Dämmern der AfD befreien, wenn auf der Gegenseite auch so ein Fundament plötzlich als nötig erachtet wird? So im Sinne von, nee, ich kann jetzt nicht einfach in die Diskussion einsteigen und sagen, ach Ampel war alles scheiße oder so, Kanzler sind alle gleich, die Altparteien, sondern so ein ganz kleines, gab es da eine Veränderung beim Verfassungsschutz, was bedeutet eigentlich ein Verfassungsschutz, Gutachten, Titel und so. Also solche kleinen Fragen. Und anlässlich des 8. Mai gab es ja jetzt einige Publikationen, bei denen ich mir vorstelle, allein dieser ganz kleine Piks in die alltägliche Diskussion, dass man nicht mehr ganz so leicht sagen kann, ich bin AfD-Anhänger oder durchscheinen lassen kann, welcher Ansicht man folgt, weil jetzt gesichert rechtsextrem mit im Diskurs schwingt, auch wenn es keine ausspricht. Aber es droht dann immer, umso mehr ausgesprochen zu werden. Dass diese klitzekleine Veränderung einen Unterschied macht zwischen 60 Millionen Tote durch den Weltkrieg oder nicht. Und das ist nicht dieses hochaufgehangene, wie war Hitler drauf, wie ist seine Psyche oder was auch immer, was hat Goebbels da gesagt, wie ist dieses Zitat zu deuten, sondern auf der ganz anderen Seite des Spektrums. In der Wählerschaft, die motivlos wählt, die einem Vibe folgt und jetzt ganz kurz durchgerüttelt wurde, weil, oh Mist, meine Leute sind gesichert rechtsextrem. Kann ich sie noch wählen und kann ich das meiner Tochter noch erklären? So ungefähr. Und es gibt hier zwei Clips, die ich mal spielen will. Das eine ist aus einer Buchbesprechung. Das Buch heißt Unwillige Volksgenossen. Es hat noch einen längeren Untertitel, der super interessant ist, aber der jetzt in meinen Clip nicht mit reingerutscht ist. Es geht um die passive Haltung der Bürger in der Anbahnung von Hitlers Macht und dann während dieses Dritten Reichs. Dieses Buch ist von Peter Langerich. Und wir hören mal einen Auszug gegen Ende des Buches, gegen Ende der Besprechung. Ein Sing-Sang, der so ein bisschen verdeutlicht, was ich hier meine.
Langerich arbeitet heraus, dass die Mehrheit zwar Hitlers außenpolitische und militärische Erfolge kutierte. Die meisten aber hatten dabei stets Angst vor einem neuen oder einem noch längeren Krieg.
Also hier schon mal ganz wichtig, ich will es für den zweiten Clip schon mal markieren. Sie kutierten die außenpolitischen Erfolge, und selbst wenn es Krieg ist. Also man sieht sich auf der Gewinnerstraße, und das scheint, könnte vielleicht das Einzige sein, was da wichtig ist. So.
Das allerdings könnte dem Regime egal sein, denn...
Zum einen ergibt sich aus den Befunden, dass eine totalitäre Diktatur auch ohne Zustimmung und Akzeptanz der Mehrheit funktionieren und ihre Ziele somit weitgehend autonom durchsetzen kann. Das ändert zum Zweiten jedoch nichts an der Gesamtverantwortung der Deutschen für die verheerenden Folgen nationalsozialistischer Politik.
Die allerdings müsse man so wörtlich neu begründen.
Denn diese Verantwortung ergibt sich nicht in erster Linie aus Begeisterung für und Übereinstimmung mit dem nationalsozialistischen Projekt, sondern primär aus einer passiven Grundeinstellung, aus mangelndem politischen Interesse, Engagement und Zivilcourage, aus dem Unwillen, sich einer eigentlich skeptisch bis ablehnend eingeschätzten Politik entgegenzustellen.
Ja, also wir haben eine politische Bewegung, die einfach sagt, die Juden sind das Übel dieser Welt. Nichts ist so nervig wie so eine kleine Minderheit, die ständig solche Erfolge vorweist. Das ganze Volk lebt in armen Häusern und die bauen sich einfach so Elfenbeintürme wie auch immer. Und daraus speist sich dann sechs Millionen industrielle Tote, 40 Millionen Kriegstote und so weiter, die ganze Welt im Karlsherr. Einfach nur, weil man 20 Jahre vorher so, ja, ich finde das schon ganz gut, wie der redet irgendwie. Und am Ende ist eben eine demokratische Machtergreifung, heißt halt einfach nur, Leute haben halt eine Stimme abgegeben. Ein kleiner Akt von drei Sekunden in einem Vierjahreszeitraum. Und wenn es vorher noch mal zehn Sekunden Irritation gegeben hätte, hätte alles ganz anders sein können.
Und das bedeutet ja auch, dass man nicht, auch wenn man natürlich diese Bilder kennt, und die gibt es ja auch, diese Dauereuphorie bei allen Bürgern hat für Hitler, sondern man sagt auch jetzt will ich hier mal jemandem Denkzettel verpassen. Und genauso leben wir das natürlich auch mit AfD-Wählern, die jetzt nicht den ganzen Tag im Klatschenmarsch verfolgen, was Alice Weidel und andere von sich geben. Aber dann, wenn es drauf ankommt, sagen sie auch jetzt könnte ich die eigentlich mal wählen.
Genau. Also selten war man bei einem Thema so nah an dieser Schmetterlings-Flügelschlag-Orkan. So dramatischerweise halt bei dem Weltkrieg. Und heute Morgen, ich habe auf dich gewartet auf dem Parkplatz da und höre Lanz und Precht mit folgendem Auszug von Lanz.
Ich fand interessant, wie Jena das begründet, was da eigentlich passiert ist. Er sagt, die Alliierten, die Briten, die Amerikaner, die sind davon ausgegangen, dass sie auf großen Widerstand stoßen würden. Die hatten insbesondere Respekt vor der Hitlerjugend, vollkommen ideologisch verblendet, fanatisiert. Und die rechneten mit Partisanenaktionen, mit Racheakten und und so weiter, weil Goebbels noch zwei Monate vor Kriegsende den insbesondere jungen Leuten eingeimpft hat. Also wenn die anderen kommen, dann werdet Werwölfe, ja, das war der Begriff. Und bringt die jeden Amerikaner und Engländer um, den ihr irgendwie zu fassen kriegt. Das heißt, davon sind die ausgegangen und waren dann völlig überrascht, dass sich sozusagen fast über Nacht der Faschismus so schreibt, das ja in diesen deutschen Seelen aufgelöst hatte. Und nichts dergleichen geschah. Sondern am Straßenrand standen jubelnde Menschen, die von den Besatzern die Schokolade nur allzu gern genommen haben, weil sie unglaublichen Hunger hatten und haben denen zugejubelt. Ja, also sie konnten sich auf etwas verlassen, womit sie gar nicht gerechnet haben. Sehr viele Deutsche, die deswegen auch Nazis gewesen sind, weil sie sich als Sieger fühlen wollten, als Überlegen und als was Tolles gegenüber anderen Völkern und auch geglaubt haben, sie gewinnen den Zweiten Weltkrieg, die haben sich dann an die neuen Sieger gehalten, damit sie wieder zu den Siegern dazugehörten.
Das kennt jeder, ich bin ja kein Anhänger von irgendwelchen Fußballvereinen und so, aber es gibt Leute, die gucken einfach nur Spiele von FC Bayern, FC Barcelona, Real Madrid.
Das kriegen wir bestimmt Ärger.
Weil da geht man einfach sicher, dass man auf der Siegerstraße ist.
Lass mich ein anderes Beispiel wählen, damit wir keine bösen E-Mails bekommen. Lohengrin ist eine sehr interessante Oper, deshalb auch, weil es ja da um einen neuen Führer geht, der Prabant beschützen soll und die sind alle in großer Aufruhr. Wer wird es denn jetzt eigentlich? Da gibt es eine Intrige im Hintergrund. Ortruht, eine Art Lady Macbeth, will ihren Mann, Telramund, als den Führer sehen. Und dann gibt es aber Elsa. Da wird geungt, die hätte ihren Bruder ermordet und sie wünscht sich einen Retter herbei. Das ist der, nach dem sie nicht fragen darf, das ist der Name, den sie nicht erfragen darf. Das ist Lohengrin. Interessant ist nun, was Wagner mit dem Chor macht in dieser Oper. Dieser Chor steht nämlich immer auf der Seite, die gerade opportun ist. Der Chor ist immer, was jetzt? Ach das, Telramund? Okay, Telramund. Ach so, Lohengrin, das ist unser neuer Führer. Prima, machen wir auch das. Der hat eigentlich genau das sehr gut herausgearbeitet. Also wer da mal die Gelegenheit hat, die Oper zu sehen und das klug inszeniert ist, dann kann man das wirklich gut zeigen, wie wankelmütig dieser Chor ist bzw. ja wie sehr er immer da rauf aus ist, bei den Siegern zu stehen.
Ja, also man ist immer bei den, finde ich, interessanten Erklärungen ganz weit abseits von Inhalten.
Ja.
So, das ist so dieses, wir machen jetzt alle Vibe-Coding und das halt auch in der Politik.
Ja, lass mich doch, wenn wir schon gerade darüber sprechen, über Vibe-Coding und alles Mögliche, einen Ausdruck vorlesen aus diesem Zeitporträt von über Kevin Kühnert, der sich ja jetzt zurückgemeldet hat, beziehungsweise sagte er, also die Politik, daraus will er sich nicht ganz verabschieden, aber erst einmal will er ein bisschen darauf auf Distanz gehen. Und dieser Artikel erzählt dann so seine Phase in der Regierung und wie er dann danach damit umgegangen ist. Das soll uns jetzt gar nicht so sehr interessieren. Was mich jedoch aufhorchen ließ, ist Folgendes. Kevin Kühnert hat sich vor einigen Jahren verliebt in einen Mann mit FDP-Parteibuch. Kühnert ist keiner, der sein Privatleben freimütig ausbreitet, aber man kann es sich so vorstellen, dass er mit seinem Partner nicht nur über die Wochenendplanung, sondern auch über Politik diskutiert. Über das Bürgergeld etwa oder die Aktienrente. Gut, das steht uns nicht anders zu beurteilen, wo die Liebe hinfällt. Jetzt wird es aber interessant. Kühnert sagt, dank seiner Beziehung habe er noch einmal neu begriffen, dass der Raum, den es braucht, um unterschiedliche Meinungen auszuhalten, nicht einfach so entsteht, sondern dass man sich um ihn bemühen, dass man ihn pflegen muss. Zitat, es braucht ständige Bewusstsein, dass der politische Gegner auch Recht haben könnte, sagt Kühnert. Und dem würde ich ganz klar widersprechen. Man kann natürlich über ganz viele Dinge diskutieren, wer hat da recht.
Aber nicht mit FDP-Land.
Nein, so will ich das nicht gemeint haben. Also ich kann natürlich über Sinn und Unsinn von Aktienrente diskutieren und da werden wir auch gar nicht so nur eine Meinung haben im Sinne von, wie viel Rendite bringt das? Dann kann man Schätzungen abgeben, kann Dinge der LGBT befragen oder was auch immer. Und dann kommt man zu vielleicht unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen und grundsätzlich. Aber ist es ja nicht so, wie zum Beispiel die Frage, wie wird der FC Bayern nächste Woche spielen, wird er gewinnen oder verlieren oder wird es unentschieden sein? Ja, da kann man unterschiedliche Auffassung sein und dann wird die Realität einen bestätigen oder widerlegen. Und es gibt natürlich Detailfragen, in denen man sich uneins sein kann und auch die andere Meinung richtig sein kann. Sollte die Umgehungsstraße nach rechts abgehen oder nach links abgehen, kommt man dann schneller rein in die Stadt oder sonst was. Das sind alles Fragen, die sind zu erörtern. Nur glaube ich, ist hier ein Denkfehler. Nämlich, wenn man sagt, es braucht das ständige Bewusstsein, dass der politische Gegner auch Recht haben könnte, denkt man Politik eigentlich so wie habermaßen nur noch in der Weise, dass man sagt, vernünftige Argumente werden ausgetauscht und das beste Argument soll gewinnen. So funktioniert ja Politik eben nicht, sondern Politik ist Interessenpolitik. Also die Gegensätze von Interessen. Die FDP vertritt grundsätzlich andere Interessen, als sie zum Beispiel eine sozialdemokratische Partei vertreten soll. Und da geht es nicht um Recht haben. Also das ist ja keine Frage von, also ich kann die ja nicht mit richtig oder falsch beantworten, die Frage wie, also zum Beispiel sollte man eine Vermögenssteuer einführen. Das ist eine Frage von Interessen. Das ist aber keine Frage von richtig und falsch. Es steht nirgends geschrieben, dass eine Gesellschaft grundsätzlich falsch ist, in der es Milliardäre gibt. Ich kann aber aus meiner politischen Überzeugung heraus sagen und im Interesse der arbeitenden Bevölkerung sprechend, wir brauchen so eine Vermögenssteuer. Aber da geht es nicht um Recht haben und wir machen einen lustigen Kompromiss oder irgendetwas, sondern da geht es ganz kaum um Interessenpolitik. Und ich glaube, das ist ein großes Problem, das sich hier im Kleinen zeigt, bei linken Parteien oder generell vielleicht auch in unseren ganzen politischen Debatten, dass wir Politik nicht als Interessenkonflikt mehr wahrnehmen wollen, sondern glauben, es ging jetzt nur darum, das beste Argument zu finden. Das ist also, es ist ein Gegensatz von Interessen. Und es ist auch nicht die Sache, dass sich Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer einig werden können über Argumentation, sondern es bleibt eine konfligierende Situation, in der man sich befindet, bei der die eine Macht stärker als die andere sein kann. Und man wählt dann zum Beispiel eine Arbeiterpartei, um die Interessen der Arbeiter zu stärken. Aber hier sieht sich natürlich Kevin Kühnert als jemand, der nicht Vorsitzender einer Arbeiterpartei sein will, sondern der das Ganze will. Und ich glaube, dass das ein fundamentales Problem ist in der linken Politik.
Finde ich auch. Also die Notwendigkeit, die Kevin Kühnert sieht, sehe ich in ganz wenigen super spezialisierten Leistungsrollen, wie zum Beispiel Bundeskanzler. Ja. Der Bundeskanzler ist immer der Bundeskanzler der ganzen Republik. Also der muss dann quasi so ein semi-presidiales die Partei hinter sich lassen. Und das hat ja Merkel zum Beispiel perfekt geschafft, sodass sie dann nach ihrer Kanzlerschaft auf Parteitage eingeladen wurde. Und vorher schon in Pressemitteilungen oder Pressekonferenzen sagte, ja, ich geh mal hin, es ist ja auch meine Partei. Also da war die Distanz schon völlig geklärt. Sie hat sozusagen diesen Kevin-Kühnert-Idealtypus gefahren, aber der...
Aber sie hat natürlich auch gewisse Interessen vertreten.
Ja, klar. Sie hat eine Herkunft. Ja, ja.
Also das ist ja jetzt auch nicht frei davon.
Nur, dass sich das jetzt als Bedarf, den man sieht, so runter transferiert, auf alle Liegenschaften, bis hin in die Wählerschaft. Ich nehme an, dieser Appell von Kevin-Kühnert ist an uns gerichtet irgendwie.
Auch dann, ja, ja.
Das ist natürlich total Banane, denn der kommt ja nur aus diesem Wunsch heraus, dass sie gegen die AfD, die demokratischen Kräfte zusammenstehen, selbst wenn sie Bindifferenzen haben, die sollen sie mal nicht so wichtig nehmen. Und da würde ich auch sagen, hier, Momentchen mal, und ich will jetzt eine Gegenerklärung liefern, die uns gleich zwei Antworten liefert. Warum gibt es überhaupt so eine Polarisierung, die als so schlecht angesehen wird? Und was hat es mit diesem politischen Spitzenpersonal auf sich? Das eben, wie wir jetzt gerade sehen, es schwer hat, diese Merkel-Rolle zu finden. Also Friedrich Merz, bei Merkel konnte Steffen Seibert noch sagen, es ist auch ihre Kanzlerin. Und man dachte sich so, ja, stimmt, aber bei Friedrich Merz, ja, also da bin ich total dagegen. Das ist nicht mein Bundeskanzler. Da bin ich immer dagegen.
Und das ist auch nicht die Frage, hat er jetzt da Recht? Also das ist ja auch, wir haben ja ganz viele rote Linien, bei denen wir auch sagen würden, ne, wir können jetzt nicht mehr darüber diskutieren, ob die Abschiebung von Minderjährigen auch mal, kann da auch mal jemand Recht haben? Da sage ich, ne, das hat man nicht recht. Und das ist meine politische Position.
Ja, und wichtig ist jetzt der Punkt, hier hilft überhaupt keine inhaltliche Aufklärung. Denn ich sage jetzt, es klingt sehr frech, aber ich glaube, das ist richtig, Friedrich Merz Position zu erklären, kann ich besser als er selber.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Und das nervt mich aber nicht an, damit übereinzustimmen. Nee.
Verstehst ihn intellektuell schon.
Christian Lindner immer verstanden. Dieses Durchpeitschen particularer Interessen und sei es zum Unwohle aller, und das widerspricht ja auch so ein bisschen dem Eid, den er damit geleistet hat als Minister. Hauptsache meine Buddies sind in Sicherheit, weil die sind eh global aufgestellt. Also die haben Kapital, das wirklich flüchten kann. Da hängt kein Handwerksbetrieb dran, der natürlich an Koblenz geklammert ist. Den bringt man nicht nach Chemnitz, nur weil die da einen anderen Hebesatz haben, die Gewerbesteuer oder sowas. Völlig absurd. So, und es gibt eine Erklärung für all das, aber aus einer Richtung, die wir nicht so mögen. Jordan Peterson war bei Joe Rogan zu Gast und ist übrigens auch in Frankfurt übernächste Woche.
Dafür machen wir das nicht noch.
Nein, nein, aber wir haben schon eine kleine Truppe gesammelt, die dann einfach mal guckt, ob es noch Abendkarten gibt, um sich das mal anzuschauen.
Ja, vielleicht gibt es Besicht von vor Ort. Was auf der Bühne geschieht, ist ja in dem Sinne uninteressant. Man kennt es ja, aber das Publikum, das zu beobachten, das wird ja die Show sein.
Also ich hab mir schon Brille und Basecap und so weiter besorgt. Ich werde dort auftauchen. Nun hat Jordan Peterson...
Entschuldigung, wie Brille und Basecap, ist das eine Verkleidung, die man braucht oder was?
Ja, ich geh da natürlich als cooler Mann hin.
Achso.
Nicht als Weichei, der ich bin. Ich geh natürlich ordentlich dahin.
Ja, okay.
Rage der Sonnenbrille.
Ja, nochmal auf, Mann.
Fotos folgen. Also, Jordan Peterson hat jetzt eine Idee vorgestellt, von der ich sage, das ist gar nicht so verkehrt, darüber nachzudenken. Er jubelt sie natürlich den Woken unter. Nur ich denke mir, selten so eine gute Heuristik gesehen, die auf ganz viele Fragen passt. Diese Fragen unterscheiden sich nicht sehr. Diese Fragen lauten, warum Friedrich Merz? Warum Jens Spahn? Warum Carsten Lindemann? Was hat es denn mit diesen Leuten auf sich? Carsten Lindemann mal in Abstrichen, aber es gilt umso mehr dann für Jens Spahn. Vielleicht können wir einfach sagen, wir erklären jetzt, wie es Jens Spahn gelangt. Und beide für die Frage, was? Einfach, dass er der erste Kanzler wird, der blau und schwarz vereint. Denn Merz wird jetzt abgeschossen, er hat sich in Sicherheit gebracht, er führt dann die Partei, jetzt die Fraktion. Soll doch die Ministerie und der Kanzler inhaltlich scheitern? Die CDU fegt ja nicht von der Weltgeschichte, nur weil Merz jetzt scheitert. Und die nächste Generation muss halt dastehen. Also, Jordan Peterson erklärt hier mal unsere Rutger Breschmann Frage. Was hat es mit diesem Spitzenpersonal auf sich? Mit denen stimmt doch irgendwas psychologisch nicht. Und die Erklärung hier lautet, ja, das sind psychopathische Parasiten und es funktioniert wie folgt.
Die Frage ist, wie man diese Menschen manövrieren kann. Und die Antwort ist, sie gehen, wo der Macht ist, und sie adoptieren diese Ideen, und sie setzen sich selbst sogar auf der Vorfront. Aber die Ideen sind völlig irrelevant. All das, was sie tun, ist, sie sind die Pharisen, sie sind die moderne Version der Pharisen. Sie sind die Menschen, die Gott im Geist benutzen. Sie proklaimieren moralische Werte.
Wir übersetzen das alles gleich, wir hören uns das erstmal im Oton an.
Das Problem, und das Recht wird das mehr und mehr besonders verbreiten, weil das Link es in den Kräften hatte, wenn sie in den Kräften waren. Wie identifizierst du die psychopathischen Parasiten? 4% der Bevölkerung. Sie sind die Menschen, die in deinem Kleid geschnitten sind und deine Flaggen wabeln. Aber sie sind nur für narcissistische Benefiz. Die Leute, die das dunkle Triad studieren, diese waren die Leute, die Psychopathen anfangs studieren. Und sie haben sich in die Ordentlichen Charaktere, so zu sagen, auf den Fringern bewegt. Sie haben gezeigt, dass die non-kriminellen Psychopathen, also die Fringe-Käse, die Machiavellianen sind. Sie benutzen ihre Sprache, um sich zu manipulieren. Sie sind narzisstisch. Sie wollen eine unerwähnte Reputation. Das ist das, was ein Narzisst will. Und sie sind psychopathisch, Das macht sie Pferde oder Parasiten. Das sind die drei Sachen ziemlich schlimm.
So, also du hast eine politische Lage, die Menschen emotional aufwühlt. Die einen wollen das Klima schützen, die anderen wollen die Familie schützen, irgendwann will sie einen Betrieb schützen. Jeder kümmert sich um irgendwas und dann gibt es vielleicht auch noch eine Tierschutzpartei, wie auch immer. Und dann gibt es in der Gesamtbevölkerung sagt er vier Prozent psychopathische Parasiten. Der psychopathische Teil daran ist, dass sie sind narzisstisch veranlagt. Ihnen ist also ihr Nasumfeld so ein bisschen egal. Sie sind sehr gut darin zu ignorieren, dass sie auf Widerstände stoßen. Es ist ihnen einfach egal. Also diese Losung, du musst nicht allen gefallen. Sobald man YouTube Videos dazu sieht, die sind ja gleich die hunderttausenden Views und so. Leute mögen diese Botschaft. Es gibt also Leute, die können das ziemlich perfekt. Und die haben eben nicht nur einen egoistischen, sondern so einen narzisstischen, biografischen Trieb nach vorn. Und sie wissen so ungefähr, wo das ist. Also versuchen sie, dieses emotionale Aufgewühltsein für sich zu nutzen. Und man erkennt sie daran, wie er beschreibt, dass sie sich erst mal in dieses Clothing, also in diese Klamotte begeben, dieser emotional aufgewühlten Gruppe dieses Milieus. Und dann die Fahne besonders deutlich schwingen.
Wir haben das ja zum Beispiel vorm Vollendet gesehen, als die Regierung ja noch aus Christian Lindner bestand. Man dort Gesetze auf den Weg bringt, die die Bauern auf den Plan rufen. Und Christian Lindner geht da so in die Menge rein, fühlt die Stimmung und sagt, ich führe euch zum Licht. Ich bin zwar eigentlich in der Regierung, aber jetzt mache ich hier Opposition für euch.
Das ist sozusagen das validierende Element, wenn man eine Evaluierung macht. Die Frage ist so ein bisschen, wenn Christian Lindner jetzt noch nicht Bundesminister der Finanzen wäre und da einfach versucht, politische Unterstützung und seine von Wähler stimmen für sich einzuhalmsen. Wie würde der 20, 30 Jahre jüngere Christian Lindner das dort nutzen? Er würde in diese Ortsverbände gehen, Ortsbeiräte, keine Ahnung, was auch immer bei einer Demo. Ich will eine Rede halten. Alle so, wir brauchen noch jemand, der eine Rede hält, will jemand, kann jemand, traut sich jemand. Er bietet es einfach an. Er ist derjenige, der die Rede hält. Er ist derjenige, der den Flyer schreibt, inhaltlich. Also er setzt sich sozusagen an die Bewegung einer Spitze, in der er sich mit Inhalten brüstet, von denen er weiß, dass sie die emotionale Schwungmasse kanalisieren, auf sich zuspitzen. Aber er selber hat damit gar nichts zu tun. Er macht es rein instrumentell.
Völlig egal.
So, und das ist eben bei Jens Spahn dieses, ein junger, schwuler Student im Münsterland überlegt sich, wie werde ich Bundeskanzler? Nehmen wir mal dieses Ziel. Ich brauche eine politische Bewegung, in der es besonders auffällt, dass man auf mich Vertrauen, Legitimation und so weiter kanalisieren kann.
Ja, also man kann schon mal nicht zu den Grünen gehen, weil dann wäre man ja einer von vielen.
Genau, da ist man ein Schwuler unter vielen. Du bist nicht schwul, aussortieren, aber so ungefähr. Wir übertreiben so ein bisschen. Er geht also in die CDU, wo alle sofort hast du gewusst, dass er schwul ist? Ja, aber der ist voll unsere Rede. Den können wir auch als Posterchild nutzen. Der wird in den Medien besonders gut funktionieren. Die haben es ja bei Horst und Hopf gehört. Also Alice Weidel ist eine lesbische Frau. Ist die da neue Hitler? Nein, das kann doch gar nicht sein. Ja, hört man von Philipp Hopf und so. Jens Spahn sucht sich also die CDU aus als Milieu und als Thema die Gesundheitspolitik, wo er weiß, darauf hat ja gar keiner Bock. Der Weg ist frei. Wenn die hier wissen, der ist engagiert inhaltlich und Gesundheitspolitiker, dann ist man quasi der nächste Gesundheitsminister.
Und er greift nebenher aber natürlich nicht die Gesundheitsthemen primär auf, um in den Medien stattzufinden. Denn die Medien interessieren sich auch in der Regel nicht für Gesundheitsthemen. Und er auch nicht. Und er eigentlich auch nicht. Aber Migration ist das Thema, das immer gut funktioniert. Islam, Islamisierung Europas, der deutschen Gesellschaft, dann auch gerne im Verbund mit, wir müssen die Frauen unterstützen, sie stärken, sie schützen vor den Migranten. Gemeinsam dann im Verbund mit Julia Klöckner. Und ja, das ist eigentlich dann die Schwungmasse, die ihr dann braucht.
Das ist die Schwungmasse für ihn.
Ja.
Er nimmt sich die Gesundheitspolitik, er nimmt sich die CDU und weiß, das ist katapultartig nach vorne, ich muss nur abends dahingehen, aufzeigen, dass ich einen Redebeitrag habe, dann richtig reinpfeffern, dann sagen die alleine. Und der ist schwul. Also der ist so überzeugt von der Sache, das ist unser Mann. So, mit dem können wir arbeiten. So, und dann möchte er aber aus dieser Gesundheitspolitik wieder raus. Also wenn ich einfach Gesundheitsminister und dann rennte, so wie Karl Lauterbach, der eben als Arzt da reingeht, und bei dem völlig klar ist, Gesundheitsminister ist die Spitze. So, danach ist Feierabend. Sondern er will ja dann weiter, ist ja Fraktionschef geworden. Dafür braucht man natürlich Truppen. Was bedeutet? Jens Spahn als psychopathischer Parasit erkennt natürlich seine Kollegen.
Gut, wir wollen nicht in dieser Weise pathologisieren.
Nein, wir sind ja nur Kommentatoren.
Wir sagen, dass es zumindest gewisse Muster in der Politik gibt, die jetzt auch Jordan Peterson angesprochen hat, die, glaube ich, jeder ganz gut nachvollziehen kann und der ein bisschen darüber nachdenkt, was da so passiert. Dann ist das ja ganz ungeheuerlich, mit welchen Charakteren man es zu tun hat. Unser eins würde acht Wochen weinend im Bett liegen, nachdem man sich dies und das geleistet hat. Die stehen am nächsten Tag da und sagen, ist ja alles gut, wir machen weiter.
Na ja, aus gewisser Sicht kann man auch sagen, das ist eine gesunde Rollendistanz. Anders geht es ja gar nicht. Man muss wie Markus Söder die Grünen abfeiern, weil irgendeine Bevölkerung gerade gesagt hat, wir haben hier irgendwie für Klimaschutz gestimmt und Umweltschutz. Und dann sind halt die Grünen am halben Jahr Konjunktur, danach ist halt wieder AfD. Und da muss man hin und her switchen.
Man hat es ja gerade gesehen bei dem CSU-Mann Huber, der war bei Markus Landzugast und ich glaube, es war von den Grünen die Franziska Brandner da. Und die Grünen haben ja mitgeholfen, dass überhaupt dieses Paket gemacht werden konnte mit den Schulden. Plus dann musste ja jetzt nochmal ein zweiter Wahlgang, da kommen wir ja auch noch im Salon drauf zu sprechen. Und man könnte ja jetzt dankbar sein, beziehungsweise könnte man sich etwas zurückhalten. Aber er haut auf die Grünen dort drauf, als sei das die schlimmste Partei, mit der man noch nie irgendwie zusammenarbeiten könnte. Und natürlich ist dann die Kohlenpolitikerin auch irritiert darüber. Aber das kann man nur machen, wenn man absolut schamlos ist. Sonst würde man es nie was sagen.
Du musst für das eigene Milieu spielen. Dass die anderen dir mal entgegengekommen sind und so, das wird bitte beim Bier geklärt. Ja mal, aber heute Nachmittag noch.
Also vor zwei Stunden haben sie dir noch geholfen. Und jetzt tust du so, als seien sie der größte Feind.
Das ist in dieser Rutger-Breschmann diese Unmenschlichkeit, die da drinsteckt, in dieser Politianspitze. Und die erkennen sich untereinander und katapultieren sich dann gemeinsam hoch, weshalb die sich halt oben so sammeln. Das hört man hier nochmal, dass es da so Zusammenschlüsse gibt.
Wir haben wirklich spezielle Mechanismen entwickelt, um solche Dinge unter Kontrolle zu halten, in Gesicht-zu-Bedeutung. Lack von Anonymy, zum Beispiel, in einer Gemeinschaft. Psychopathen im echten Leben, sie wandern. Sie müssen von Ort zu Ort aus, weil die Leute, die wissen, wer sie sind, und sie sind hängen verantwortlich. Sie sind besonders hängen verantwortlich von Männern. Aber online, sie schlagen sich von diesem, sie schlagen sich von diesem Protektiv, sie schlagen sich von diesem System von Kontrainten aus, und sie haben freie Reine, und sie finden andere Leute wie sie sehr schnell, und sie können zusammenfangen. Und so ist das so, ich sehe das wirklich anfangen zu passieren auf der rechten Seite. Ich habe psychopathische Behörde auf der rechten Seite für wahrscheinlich vier Jahre, etwas wie das, besonders auf der antisemitischen Seite, weil das wirklich das Vorhinein ist. Und...
Warum ist das so?
Es ist nichts mehr anstrengend als eine erfolgreiche Minorität.
Also es gibt verschiedene Schwungmassen, die man immer wieder nutzt. Und dann muss man sich erkennen. Also da empfehle ich sehr als wirklich wahnsinnig gute Aufklärung über solche eben inhaltsbefreite Sachen. Es ist ja, bevor ich sage, worüber ich gleich kurz was ich nur empfehle, wenn ich sage, der Wähler wählt motivlos. Und wenn wir jetzt sagen, die sind psychopathischen Parasiten, denen es an der Spitze von solchen Bewegungen so gut tut, denen sind die Inhalte auch egal. Die wollen einfach nur ihren Vorteil nutzen. Dann muss man ernst nehmen, dass es da nicht um Inhalte geht. Wenn ich also jetzt sage, die beste Aufklärung über das moderne politische Geschehen gibt es im Amerikanischen, nicht im Deutschen, jetzt keine E-Mails. Jedes Mal, wenn ich das im Podcast erwähnt habe, egal in welchem Podcast, gab es immer E-Mails mit und so weiter. Ich meine nicht das deutsche Fernsehprogramm mit, sondern ich meine die US-amerikanische Version von Big Brother. Die muss man gucken. Da werden Allianzen geschmiedet, bevor man guckt, was der Tag so bringt. Und dann müssen die Allianzen durchhalten, egal was der Tag so bringt. Da spielen Inhalte keine Rolle. Da geht es nur um, schaffen es die Girls jetzt eine All-Girls-Alliance zum Schmieden? Oder funkt da doch wieder eine sich anbahnte Liebesbeziehung rein? Oder wie auch immer. Also da ist einfach das amerikanische Big Brother, wo die halt wirklich konklave-mäßig abgeschlossen sind. Da passiert nichts von außen, das in das Haus hineinwirkt. Da geht es nur um die Frage, wer sortiert hier wen aus und mit wessen Hilfe. Und da müssen sich, da würde ich jetzt sagen, das sind dann keine psychopathischen Parasiten, das sind einfach normale Menschen. Aber man erkennt sofort, wenn da jemand das Spiel besonders gut studiert hat, die letzten 30 Seasons, die es da gab. Also das sollte man sich da anschauen.
Wir haben jetzt nicht nur einen neuen Papst, sondern auch einen Bundeskanzler. Und ich will dir einen Tweet vorlesen von Friedrich Merz, nachdem er mit Trump gesprochen hat. Schrieb er, ich habe heute mit Präsident Trump telefoniert und teile seine Forderung. Das Töten in der Ukraine muss ein Ende finden und Russland einem Waffenstillstand zustimmen. Das ist der Friedrich Merz, der sagte, wenn ich Kanzler bin, dann gibt es sofort Taurus. Und wir hatten ja noch mal im April so eine ganz kleine Taurus-Debatte gehabt. Und interessant ist, dass wir jetzt solche Töne da hören. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, was da lossteht. Friedrich Merz, stramm an der Seite von Putin. Kann man mit einem Diktator verhandeln?
Merz möchte nicht mehr über Waffengattungen reden jetzt.
Interessant. Es ist wirklich hochinteressant. Diese ganze Debatte, auch von der CDU geführt. Nur jetzt Taurus und so weiter. Und Schulz, der Zögerer, Zauderer. Jetzt, er ist Kanzler. Zwei Tage später ein solcher Tweet.
Ja, es ist erstaunlich, dass es überhaupt sowas wie moderne Politik gibt.
Ja.
Und noch erstaunlicher, dass man Menschen findet, die das wollen und noch erstaunlicher, dass es welche gibt, die es auch können. Und jetzt sind wir gerade in einer Phase, in der es die falschen wollten. Es ist nicht ganz, also dieser Filmkonklave.
Der ist gut, aber richtig gut ist der Trailer für diesen Film. Weil in diesem Trailer wird einfach die Essenz geklärt. Die ganze Kirche gibt es wegen Glauben. Die Glaube gibt es wegen dem Mysterium. Das Mysterium gibt es wegen dem Zweifel. Und der Gewissheit, die Gewissheit ist der Teufel. Wenn man die Gewissheit hätte und so weiter und so fort. So und diese ganze Idee, dass es Konklave stattfindet unter der Bedingung des Zweifels, dass man also nicht die Gewissheit hat, jetzt den besten Papst zu wählen. Und das einzige Programm, das sich dieser Kurienkardinal, der diese Konklave dann leitet, stellt, ist, die Konklave sortiert aus, wer zu sehr Papst werden möchte. Und übrig bleibt, nach 17 Wahlgängen, den, den man händeringend überreden muss, damit er es endlich macht.
Aber dann gibt es immer wieder diese Zweifel im Film natürlich. Ich hoffe, am Ende doch alle wirklich wollen und auch nur so tun, als würden sie nicht wollen. Was ich dem Film ja übel nehme, aber viele werden ihn jetzt vielleicht zum ersten Mal sehen, deswegen will ich nicht zu viel verraten.
Die desizinische Kapelle beschädigt wird.
Nein, was ich ihm übel nehme, ist, dass ja dann ein Kandidat aus dem Hut gezaubert wird, quasi der aufgrund einer flammenden Rede zum Papst gewählt wird. Und dies ist da natürlich etwas sehr Progressives, so wird es zumindest dargestellt. In Wahrheit ist das ja was ungeheuer populistisches, beziehungsweise da ist die große Frage, also ist jemand geeignet, nur weil er gut zu denen sprechen kann, der ist er, der jetzt im Prinzip auch diese Schwungmaße nimmt, der ideale Papst. Also was hier getan wird, ist ja eigentlich, dass der der große Rhetoriker ausgezeichnet wird. Und man hat damit eigentlich so eine charismatische Herrschaft, die man haben möchte, noch einmal ganz klar unterstrichen. Und das ist sicherlich ein Manko dieses Films. Oder der der literarischen Vorlage, muss man sagen. Bei Robert Harris ist es ja genauso.
Ja, also richtig für alle, die den Film noch nicht geguckt haben. Meine Lesart wäre genau entgegen. Die Konklave ist auch dafür da, damit man Gespräche führt unter sich, von denen die Weltöffentlichkeit niemals erfährt. Das heißt, die große Rede ist eigentlich eine kleine Rede. Und am Ende überzeugen doch die Merkmale des Sprechers mehr, als die Rede selbst.
Sie wissen nichts über ihn. Sie kennen nur diese Rede. Sie beurteilen nur die Rede. Das ist durchaus problematisch.
Ja, aber Reden haben halt Ansicht, dass sie in einem Film gut funktionieren, weil sie sehr viel Inhalt transportieren. Und deswegen etwas zu sehr im Vordergrund stehen für die eigentlich ist.
Richtig, aber sie beurteilen dort eine Person, ob diese für das höchste Amt geeignet ist. Nur anhand einer einzelnen Rede werden sie von den anderen ungeheuer viel wissen.
Das ist halt Conclave, der Podcast Die sogenannte Gegenwart, begann damit, dass Nina Power sagte, ich komme gerade aus der Redaktionskonferenz. Hier sind alle schon genervt von Conclave. Einige Kollegen haben zu mir gesagt, ich will nie wieder gehört kriegen, wie die Conclave funktioniert. Und ich sage, nein, das ist das Allerwichtigste. Die entscheidende Frage ist nicht, wer wird Papst, welche Kardinale sind da und wie auch immer, sondern das Conclave selbst ist vom Prinzip her eine Errungenschaft. Die Kirche, mehr hat das noch mal im Büro geschrieben, es gab Zeiten, da ist einfach eine Taube auf jemanden gelandet und dann hieß es, das ist Gottes Zeichen, du bist jetzt Papst und es wurde als Bürde verstanden.
Ja, natürlich, die Taube, da ist ja der Heilige Geist und der Heilige Geist wählt ja quasi mit.
Ja, Conclave ist jedenfalls durch diese Abgeschiedenheit, und zwar eine innerweltliche Abgeschiedenheit, da sind Menschen eingeschlossen. Man bedient sich da nicht noch mal irgendwelchen, nicht hier noch mal LGBT-Fragen oder wie auch immer, das ist übrigens auch im Bundestag, die machen diesen ersten Wahlgang, kommen nicht weiter, alle Fraktionen ziehen sich erst mal zehn Minuten zurück und jeder fragt bei LGBT nach, was sagt denn das Grundgesetz dazu? Und danach kommen die Konferenzen zwischen den Fraktionen. Das ist halt so eine blöde Geschichtsschreibung. Und ich will bei dem Conclave noch mal darauf hinweisen, wir haben auf der einen Seite jetzt eine Woche gehabt, in der einfach Conclave war und das war die Botschaft an die ganze Welt, ihr könnt jetzt ein bisschen meditieren, der Stuhl ist vakant, wenn Journalisten euch irgendetwas sagen, die wissen nicht mehr als ihr. Es gibt keine Botschaften außer schwarz oder weißer Rauch. Alles, was Journalisten gesagt haben, bis zur Verkündung des Namens, ist völlig Waffengleichheit im Publikum. Anders in der Kanzlerwahl. Angela Merkel hat jetzt mehrfach betont, dass sie Friedrich Merz alles Gute wünscht und ihn auch unterstützt, weil er ihr gezeigt hat, dass er es wirklich will. Man braucht die Verbissenheit zur Macht. Also es ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was wir bei der Conclave uns idealtypisch finden.
Natürlich, man hat es auch wieder einen mitgegeben, in dem sie dort war für den ersten Wahlgang und dann für den zweiten sich entschuldigen ließ, weil sie noch einen Termin hatte.
Genau, das ist alles sehr gut. So, wir müssen noch mal kurz eine Aufklärung machen. Ich hatte nämlich im letzten Mal, Bayer hat ja Monsanto gekauft, nicht BASF. So, sehr viele Hinweise dazu, weshalb ich noch mal darauf hinweisen möchte, dass bei solchen Fragestellungen, ich habe dann einfach GPT oder ich sage mal allgemein, ich habe es nicht GPT gegeben. Deswegen, also ich habe der KI, es gibt ja zum Glück plural, unser Transkript gegeben und habe gesagt, angenommen, ich möchte mich jetzt rausreden, was ist denn mit BASF? Und es stellt sich raus, es werden doch sehr wohlmeinende, wohlgeschätzte, mir entgegenkommende Antworten angeboten. Also die KI mag mich und sagt oder weist darauf hin, dass BASF auch ohne, dass man jetzt einen großen Deal gemacht hat in Amerika, doch krass verankert ist, alle großen Produktionsstätten, die größten weltweit, die BASF, sind alle in Amerika. Ein Viertel des Gesamtumsitzes findet dort statt. Man hat sich lobbymäßig komplett eingekramt, also man ist da richtig präsent. Und wenn solche Märkte da wegbrechen, das könnte man wahrscheinlich jetzt für jedes DAX-Unternehmen mal durchgehen. So wie die Verknüpfungen nach Amerika sind, weil dieser Absatzmarkt da so gewaltig ist, weil denen das so scheißegal war, was es kostet. Die verschönen sich alle auf Billionen und Billionen, um einfach Atti das Sneaker zu tragen und so ein Kram. Also es ist wirklich gewaltig, was jetzt hier gerade von Donald Trump aufgeschlüsselt wird.
Ich will noch nachtragen, oder das wurde häufig jetzt gefragt, wer ist das denn eigentlich? Ich habe da einen Fitness-Coach gespielt, der den Männern sagte, also ihr seid keine Krieger und keine Helden, nur weil ihr mal Gewichte stemmt. Und ihr könnt auch Gewichte stemmen, aber ihr müsst dann nicht gleich die Agenda der Rechten übernehmen. Diesen findet man bei Instagram. Der heißt Colin, also mit C, Unterstrich, Coaches.
Ja, Colin Coaches.
Dann wird man den sehen und wird dort sonst nur Fitnessvideos finden, aber dann auch dieses eine Video.
Wir verlinken ihn in der Podcast-Beschreibung. Ihr könnt also in der App gleich darunter scrollen und es sich anschauen. Ich verlinke uns beide auch nochmal, denn ich brauche jetzt mehr als 10.000 Follower bei Instagram. Das geht nicht, dass ich da nur so ein kleines Licht bin.
Ich habe, ich habe glaube ich über 30.000.
Ja, das ist nicht gut, ich muss aufholen.
Na ja, also jetzt müssen auch alle mich abonnieren, damit Stefan mich nicht überholt. So, wir werden jetzt im Salon über zwei Bücher zunächst sprechen. Einmal Abundance, How We Build a Better Future von Esra Klein und Derrick Thompson. Das ist ein Buch, das sich kritisch, nicht nur mit dem Neoliberalismus auseinander setzt erfreulicherweise, sondern auch kritisch mit den Linken, den Liberalen, denn diese haben verlernt, wie man eigentlich etwas baut, erfindet, verbreitet. Das ist die These von Abundance. Es ist der Wunsch danach, dass endlich wieder was erschaffen wird. Zum Beispiel Wohnungen ist ein Buch, das sich auf Amerika bezieht, aber wir werden natürlich sehr viele Parallelen zu uns ziehen können. Als zweites sprechen wir dann über das Buch Die Welt nach dem Kapital von Risikokapital Investor Albert Wenger.
Was erwartet uns da?
Dieses Buch wurde vorgestellt in Berlin von Wenger und Franziska Brandner, also der grüne Vorsitzende. Und ich dachte mir, naja, dann werden die ja auch doch offenbar Relevantes hier. Also wird doch dieses Buch offenbar wichtig sein, wenn da eine Frau, die sich auch mit der Wirtschaft auskennt, die quasi Habecks rechte Hand war bei so einer Buchpremiere.
Die wir im Podcast schon gelobt haben, als wir noch einfache Abgeordnete im Europaparlament waren.
Und jetzt lesen wir dieses Buch und haben so unsere Zweifel daran, dass das wichtig ist. Aber es ist sehr typisch, glaube ich, für die Sachbuchproduktion heute und sehr typisch für das, wie über Wirtschaft nachgedacht wird. Also es ist wirklich ein interessantes Konglomerat falschen Denkens.
Wir müssen eine neue Unterscheidung einfügen. Wir haben ja bisher immer mal unterschieden zwischen Informativen und Inspirativen lesen. Das können wir jetzt zusammenklammern als das Ertragreiche lesen. Und dieses Buch werden wir mal so als Abarbeitung lesen. Also es stehen ein paar Sätze drin, über die wir nicht hinweggehen können. Die werden wir vorlesen. Und dann machen wir uns da auch Gedanken zu. Es ist sozusagen negative Schwungmasse, die wir nutzen.
Aber es ist in gewisser Weise auch eine Ergänzung zu dem Buch von Alex K. In einer ganz verqueren Weise.
Aber ich finde es besser, dass wir es direkt im Tandem mit Abundance lesen und nicht mit Alex K.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Alex K haben wir ja auch schon besprochen von daher. Ich möchte außerdem vorstellen, ein Essay über Künstliche Intelligenz von Peter Schad, der eine sehr gute und marxistische Perspektive einnimmt auf das Thema KI.
Das ist ein Essay, also als Heft?
Ja, das ist im Marlboro Verlag. Die geben solche Hefte heraus. Das sind immer so 35 Seiten.
Hat nicht mal Seitenzahlen.
Doch, es hat Seitenzahlen. Ist auch illustriert. Doch, doch, es gibt Seitenzahlen. Und die widmen sich dann immer einem Thema und das ist jetzt Künstliche Intelligenz. Außerdem habe ich ein interessantes Interview gelesen mit Katharina Pisto. Die ist ja uns bekannt durch ihr Buch Der Code des Kapitals und sie lehrt in den USA und erklärt, was da in den Unis so gerade unter Trump passiert. Weiter habe ich ein Buch von Joanne Beard, eine amerikanische Schriftstellerin. Großartig. Also ich bin ganz begeistert davon. Dann müssen wir auch mal Kritik an der Linkspartei üben. Ich habe einen Artikel aus Jacobin. Was ist da eigentlich passiert, dass die Linkspartei Friedrich Merz eine zweite Wahl an diesem Tag ermöglichte? Und inwieweit ist das sinnvoll gewesen? Sehr interessanter Beitrag von Sebastian Friedrich. Und Alisara Ott ist eine hervorragende Pianistin, die uns einen Komponisten zu Gehör bringt, den ich vorher gar nicht kannte, der vor knapp 200 Jahren gestorben ist, John Field. Und der hat quasi das Nachtstück erfunden, die Nocturns. Und das ist also Musik für die Nacht.
Oh, okay, ich bin gespannt. Wir lesen in einem Rutsch drei Texte aus der New York Times zu Trumps Fertilitätspolitik. Ich habe das ja im Buch bei mir schon angedeutet, in welche Richtung das da so geht, inklusive technischen Entwicklungen, wie brauchen wir überhaupt noch Frauen für Kinder und so. Und die Widersprüche könnten kaum größer sein. Die Regierung will etwas und macht aber gleichzeitig Demokratieabbau. Also Demokratieabbau, aber vor allem Bürokratieabbau. Das passt ja nicht zusammen, wenn man eine Geburtenzahl auch dadurch steigern möchte, dass man künstlich assistiert. Und dann gibt es aber diesen Forschungszweig gar nicht mehr, weil der ist natürlich allein von der Regierung finanziert. Wer sollte das finanzieren? Also diese Widersprüche sind so enorm. Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Dann lesen wir einen super wichtigen und super guten Text von Andreas Püttmann. Ich kenne schon ein bisschen von Twitter und so. Er hat in den Blättern über das Christliche und das Konservative und wie es eigentlich nicht zusammenpasst. Und die CDU das immer versuchte und sich jetzt komplett verirrt hat. Ich habe gedacht, das kann ja gar nicht sein. Das ist ja total logisch, was hier steht. Also wirklich erstaunlich. Und Walter Beuerns hat im Freitag ein Interview gegeben zum Thema, da steht ja eine Überschrift, zum fünften Mal verzichten wir auf Vermögenssteuer. Und ich habe dann auf Basis dieses Interviews, dieser Aussagen, mal Gemini, den Koalitionsvertrag und das Wahlprogramm der SPD gegeben, um zu fragen, wie weit hat Walter Beuerns da Recht? Und wir gehen dann mal Punkt für Punkt durch, was die SPD forderte und was nicht im Koalitionsvertrag steht. Also wirklich erschütternd. Dieses KI-Zeitalter sollte uns sofort instant Aufklärung geben, wenn irgendwer irgendwo irgendwas Politisches sagt, vor allem wenn er Amtsverantwortung hat. Ich finde, wir haben ja schon beim letzten Mal, wie Human hart aber fair geguckt hat, eine Landsendung, in der Markus Söder einfach irgendwas sagt und niemandem einen Zettel reinreicht, um sofort der Widerspruch zu üben, darf es nicht mehr geben. Also die Zeitenwende muss jetzt stattfinden, denn das, was wir an innerlicher Aufklärung hier instantan kriegen, ist, so kann man keine Gesellschaft bauen.
Wir sind sehr gespannt und wer das auch hören möchte, kann das natürlich tun durch ein Abo. Das ist möglich über Steady, Apple oder Patreon. Es ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Man geht auf die Seite neuzwanziger.de. Dort ist ein goldener Salon-Button, auf den klickt man. Dann kommt man zu Steady und kann dort ein Abo abschließen. Drei Euro im Monat und dann hat man auch Zugriff zu allen Folgen, die schon erschienen sind. Das heißt viele, viele Bücher, dutzende Bücher. Ich glaube, über 100 Bücher sind das jetzt inzwischen. Mehr, die wir ja schon besprochen haben und empfehlenswerte Texte. Außerdem natürlich auch die Live-Salons, die viermal im Jahr stattfinden. Das ist also über Steady möglich. Wer schon bei Patreon ist, kann uns auch darüber hören. Und jetzt für die Apple-Nutzer ist es im Prinzip noch einfacher, wenn auch dann minimal teurer, weil Apple ja noch klar einen extra Share haben will. Wie geht das, wenn man das jetzt bei Apple Podcast hört?
Man ist ja eh schon in der Apple Podcast App, wahrscheinlich. Darüber hören jedenfalls sehr viele, ungefähr so 25 Prozent der Leute, die uns hören. Und dann taucht ja einfach die Folge da auf, eben nicht mit einem Play, sondern mit einem Kaufbutton. Und dann abonniert man und dann kriegt man sie pro Monat direkt im Feed mitgeliefert.
Wir würden uns also freuen, wenn ihr auf diese Weise den Podcast unterstützt. Denn das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit, den Podcast zu unterstützen. Und es gibt sehr viel zu hören. Wir werden jetzt ausführlich diskutieren über diese Bücher.
Keine Wolfgang Büsten im Merch?
Nein, wird es auch nicht geben. Was mir übrigens noch wichtig ist zu sagen, weil einige mich angeschrieben haben in Bezug auf mein iPhone, welchen Messenger ich dann jetzt nutzen würde oder sowas. Das mache ich eben nicht. Also nur weil man jetzt ein Smartphone hat, muss man sich nicht alle Apps dieser Welt herunterladen. Ich habe keine Social Media App auf dem Smartphone und ich habe auch keinen Messenger. Ich kann SMS verschicken bzw. iMessage und ich kann das ganz Verrückte anrufen. Und das ist absolut ausreichend. Ich möchte auch nicht in Familiengruppen und andere Gruppen hinein. Ja, das ist alles nicht vonnöten. Deshalb möchte ich ja ein Smartphone haben, um mir das Leben zu erleichtern und mir jetzt nicht mehr Ballast aufzulassen.
Ja, ich will nochmal, weil extrem viele Fragen kamen, welches Auto, welches Telefon überhaupt und so. Also wir haben so viel darüber geredet beim letzten Mal, weil ich auf dem Weg hierher dich einfach fragte, welche Features hat denn dein Auto dann? Ein Platten-Spieler, weil ich weiß ja, dein altes Auto war ja übersät mit CD's und so weiter. Also war einfach nur so ein Joke, woraufhin sich herausstellte, Musik hören kann man in dem Auto nur mit Telefon. So irgendwie.
Wäre das einzig Sinnvolle, ja.
Genau, so. Und deswegen kam die Frage auf, mit welchem Telefon hört denn Wolfgang in seinem Auto Musik?
Ich habe das mit dem iPhone ja nur jetzt gemacht, weil du eins hast, weil viele meinem Umkreis ein iPhone haben und sie sagten, das sei besonders sicher und besonders gut.
Wir hoffen das einfach.
Denke ich, dass ihr recht habt und ich habe jetzt die notwendigen Apps drauf. Was ich jetzt habe, ist zum Beispiel die Bahn Bonus App, denn ich genieße ja schon seit einiger Zeit einen Goldstatus, den ich aber nie einlösen konnte. Weil ich ja viel fahre, und jetzt dank des Goldstatus konnte ich auch zum ersten Mal in die DB Lounge am Hauptbahnhof Frankfurt. Und jetzt konnte ich also literweise Cola-Lei trinken. Ist das nicht schön.
Gut, so den Rest besprechen wir dann im Salon. Bis gleich.